[Music]
ever since humanity emerged we all had
the depth to one another we are a
collaborative species we survived the
evolutionary struggle in the jungle
Landis steps in the desert only through
collaboration collaboration requires
reciprocity I do something for you today
you do something for me to tomorrow that
is it that it's a form of that but it's
a non-financial non economic that is an
ethical that it's it's the good side of
that as society became commodified and
all activities started getting channeled
through the anonymous market most of
this reciprocity took the form of
financial debt
what turbocharged the economy once the
economy got separated from society
through this process of commodification
was banking because let's face it
bankers have a fantastic power over the
rest of society by definition by vehicle
their very existence to create money
when you get a loan from a bank
it is a crazy idea that you're getting
it from somebody else you're not getting
from somebody else
it is not true this is a major fallacy
that occupies most people's minds
in fact most people's minds that you are
being given money that somebody else has
saved that is not true what the bank
does it creates money from thin air it
just types into your account you know
$20,000 if you borrow $20,000 it's it it
comes literally out of thin air
and the hope of the banker is you will
be able to repay it because what happens
is you take that 20,000 you buy
equipment for your studio you buy a new
bicycle and your car whatever so the
money goes from your bank account to the
bank account of the company or the
person that sold you something and the
idea is that through this circular flow
of income and through this economic
activity a new income is going to be new
value will be created you will be able
to repay the bank the bank
could obtain the interest and therefore
the bank is going to profit so the more
they lend to you the more profits they
make so it is a little bit and that's
why I try to explain to my daughter in
the book it's a little bit like the bank
as having a capacity to push the arm
through the timeline into the future and
grab value that has not been created yet
bring it to the present invest it into
some productive activity hopefully to
create the value that we need to repay
the future but if to the extent this is
successful women has always been
successful Bank is suddenly get the idea
that the more they reach into the future
the more value they snatch from the
future to bring it into the present the
greater their own personal profit but
when they overdo it and of course they
always overdo it they overreach they
take too much value from from the future
bring it into the present that value is
not realized and then you have a banking
crisis and because they play such a
crucial and powerful role in society
they have the political clout political
clout that you and I don't have and
because usually they are the ones who
finance our politicians to get elected
to the Congress and so on that can use
the political system in order to have
themselves bailed out you know socialism
for the bankers and austerity for
everybody else
you